[Música]
antes de qualquer coisa
saibam que é uma alegria enorme estar
aqui eu meu braço engessado por alguns
meses
a thaísa me telefonou e me fez um
convite paulo nós vamos realizar em
maceió um ted e gostaríamos muito que
você estivesse presente para falar sobre
mudança de vida
em meu coração se iluminou na mudança de
vida é mesmo assunto que me faz
transbordar está aqui hoje para falar
sobre as pequenas granadas que movem o
mundo é falar sobre mudança de vida e
falar sobre mudança de vida é falar
sobre a aceitação plena do presente e ao
mesmo tempo nos lembrar da nossa
condição de finitude
porque se estamos em busca de mudanças
se estamos em busca de algo que faça o
nosso coração vibrar
estamos em busca de entusiasmo
nós estamos em busca de uma vida mais
realizada uma vida mais feliz e uma vida
que naquele momento que nos despedimos
dela
nós sentimos que de fato fez sentido e
essa minha vida começou muito cedo
começou bem cedo quando aos 14 anos eu
me vi grávida
a clara semana que vem completa 18 anos
e naquele momento eu tinha certeza que
eu ia morrer eu não ia da luz eu ia
morrer
de tão difícil que me parecia aquele
cenário de tão difícil que nem parecia
um
a minha vida tanto daquele jeito parece
inconcebível como eu consigo sobreviver
a essa mudança tão grande e não só eu
mas as pessoas que estavam ao meu redor
meu pai minha mãe meu coração ficava
completamente abalada imaginando o meu
pai e minha mãe vivendo uma mudança tão
inesperado assim então eu me enche de
alguma força
sabe-se lá de onde vêm esses momentos de
mudança ea gravidez seguiu bem depois
que os meus pais tiveram ao meu lado me
ajudaram em tudo o que foi preciso eu
segui meus estudos
ao lado da minha filha crescendo
aprendendo desenvolvendo e percebendo
graças àquela lição daquele momento
chave que ao invés de morrer
eu estava me sentindo muito mais viva do
que antes
eu estava me sentindo muito mais forte
do que antes
e aquele foi o primeiro lampejo de uma
história de sucessão de mudanças que me
ensinou muito pra todo o restante da
história que ainda estava esperando
quando a clara tinha por volta de seus
11 anos eu juntei mala e cuia e nos
mudamos para manaus
a cuia clara ver uma mãe eu te odeio eu
não quero mudar de minas para rodá los
em manaus
uau que diversidade e quanta aprendizado
cinco anos naquela cidade rodeada por
árvores por rios quanto a floresta
quantas pessoas acolhedoras quanto eu
aprendi sobre ser água naquela cidade
quanto eu aprendi sobre sermos o fluxo
que nós viemos ser eo alvo
ganhei um braço engessado 15 dias antes
de vidro
sede em manaus eu pude ver não só um
casamento por que eu me casei
uma semana antes de me mudar para manaus
durou um ano
poucos anos depois não sei como coube
cinco anos de manaus tudo que aconteceu
não tem o menor sentido dentro da
história
dois anos depois já estava casada de
novo meu casamento durou um ano de novo
tenho habilidade e aprende quanto quanto
eu aprendi sobre viver e aceitar as
mudanças e viver e provocar as mudanças
em manaus e eu que sou sedentária por
constituição histórica inclusive foi uma
grande vantagem da adolescência quando
eu me vi grávida e mãe eu fui liberada
da educação física do colégio que foi
maravilhoso que foi o grande plus olha
você não precisa mais fazer educação
física foi porque você é mãe então eu
aceito não tem problema eu recebo em
manaus eu vivi de repente desejando meus
olhos brilham no sonhando em seguir rumo
ao topo de uma montanha o monte roraima
foi como se ele tivesse se iluminado
diante dos meus olhos e vocês sabem bem
do que estou falando
existem momentos da vida que algo se
ilumina diante de nós aquilo se torna
como uma luz que você quer naquela
direção e os outros podem dizer 'você tá
doido não faz o menor sentido você só
pode estar ficando maluca como a cimpor
uma montanha se não sai nem do sem sair
da sua cidade para fazer uma caminhada
mais longa
eu tinha certeza meu coração sabia
vai pra montanha eu me preparei como
pude sedentária que sou pelo menos eu
fui pra academia com a mochila nas
costas fazendo besteira fazer alguma
coisa em 2011 em junho de 2011
eu pegava a minha mochila ele todos os
meus medos e em direção àquela montanha
que se tornou um grande símbolo
de toda a mudança que já tinha
experimentado na minha vida
naquele momento eu tinha acabado de me
separar do meu primeiro casamento já
tinha clara já estava com 12 12 anos eu
acho que já sabia da força que as
mudanças provocam em nós mas eu não
tinha dimensão da força que aquela
experiência e dos símbolos que aquela
experiência traria pra minha caminhada
como uma água que eu sou como um rio que
nós somos seguir rumo ao topo daquela
montanha com todos os meus medos na
mochila
tendo consciência que mais importante do
que olhar pra grandeza daquela montanha
todo o tempo
quero olhar para os meus pés e me
concentrar no passo dado
olhar para onde estava indo ter uma
referência de lugar tem uma referência
de sonho de meta mas seguir confiante
olhando pro meu pé porque o passo parece
que não rende muito mais ele rende
demais eu cheguei naquele topo e voltei
pra casa tendo tanta tanta clareza de
que os topos da nossa vida
são muitos pequenos e grandes que os
topos da nossa vida é um grande símbolo
da mudança que nós buscamos de tudo
aquilo que faz sentido para o nosso
coração cada um tem seus próprios topos
e não é a mãe quem é o pai
são os outros que vão dizer é ali
naquele topo que brilha pra você é o teu
coração e o meu coração me dizia monte
roraima e aquele monte me trouxe de
volta à minha casa com a certeza que eu
precisava transformar a minha vida uma
vez mais
integrando
tanto as partes sendo realizada
o máximo que eu pudesse em cada uma das
áreas da minha vida como mãe como
profissional como esposa como filha
qualquer paula sendo realizada
plenamente
eu comecei naquele momento o maior
movimento de transformação da minha
história
recolhendo tudo que havia de valioso
dentro de mim e me lembrando do ser
valioso que eu sou e que todos nós somos
pela singularidade que nós carregamos
lembrando da minha finitude e portanto
da urgência que eu sentia em fazer
aquela mudança e transformando a minha
vida pra ela ficar tão boa quanto era a
vida quando eu ia para a montanha
voltei ao monte roraima outras três
vezes num mesmo ano e ninguém me
aguentava falando de montanha mas o
papel o papel é muito mais paciente e
foi por isso que eu escrevi meu primeiro
livro e parecem para o novo erro
ele nasceu porque eu precisava colocar
em algum lugar a história mais de carro
forte que estava vivendo e depois dessas
três vezes eu me vi construindo um novo
cumprir a minha vida de uma profissão
que me fizesse sentir plena realizada de
uma vida ao lado da minha filha que me
fizesse sentir mais mãe ainda do que
antes mas principalmente a transformação
de que a vida é esse fluxo de que a vida
é uma constante mudança que a vida é
essa surpresa e ela é assim e nos
lembrarmos que somos a água e que somos
seres em transformação e que podemos sim
fazer tudo o que os nossos sonhos dizem
é lá tudo o que o nosso coração enxerga
como brilhando diante dos nossos olhos
ao aprender sobre tudo isso eu aprendi
sobre o mais importante valor que hoje
eu carrego seja escrevendo meus livros
nos meus cursos estando aqui que minha
grande missão é salvar a mim mesma me
salvar me lembrar que eu sou ser mais
importante desse mundo
e ao me salvar e ao me lembrar que eu
sou ser mais importante desse mundo eu
salvo os outros eu salvo mundo com essa
perspectiva
eu acordo a cada manhã me lembro da
minha finitude me conecto com o que eu
estou sentindo e me pergunto tão simples
qual a mudança eu preciso fazer hoje
para viver a vida que eu quero viver
nesse dia e há 15 dias antes de vir pra
cá
estando em uma viagem com a minha filha
não saltando de paraquedas não subindo
uma montanha mas em casa no apartamento
de uma viagem
eu caí da escada e quebrei meu punho é
só uma escritora descreve como direito a
mais à esquerda é tão valiosa quanto
quando eu estou lá no computador
digitando os meus textos
eu me vi diante de uma certeza plena de
que minha única é a única função ali era
identificar o que aquela situação tava
me ensinando o que essa situação de vir
aqui no meu ted falar sobre mudança de
vida cuidando do meu braço que está
quebrado e engessado e assim poder uma
vez mais olhar pra minha condição de
finitude que não precisa ser um punho
quebrado um capotamento como eu vivi
estando lá no amazonas
não precisa ser um grande evento para me
lembrar da minha finitude eu sou nós
sons ea realização é a minha meta de
vida fazer valer a pena essa vida
maravilhosa essa vida que me foi dada
como presente
agora a mudança de vida é essa sensação
aqui dentro de que algo pode ser feito
de que sentimos que é preciso fazer algo
de que algo nos chama
mas dá medo
dá medo e eu senti medo quando eu me vi
deitada no chão vi que o punho estava
fora do lugar ele não tava não está bem
clara quebrei quebrei o punho
vamos pro hospital até aí estava
tranquilo quando me lembrei eu tô na
espanha como esses espanhóis usam coisas
métodos espanhóis para colocar um punho
lugar
eu comecei meu deus ora com que esses
não são muito gentis assim no trânsito
já tinha vindo eles gritando vou colocar
meu punho como método e fique sem medo
medo também quando eu sentir como eu
senti quando eu estava no meu curso de
paraquedismo porque manaus também me
proporcionou essa é sua plenitude
então você se o curso de paraquedismo
tal como as montanhas ele têm símbolos
maravilhosos ali que você está diante de
algo que você não conhece você está na
porta daquele avião
você tá na plataforma sólida até ali mas
quando você vai pisar para além daquela
plataforma você não conhece é o novo é a
mudança que você tem mesmo a mesma
sensação daquela que eu experimentei
quando estava lá nos meus 14 anos
grávida eu vou morrer eu vou morrer
a mudança faz isso mas faz isso não
porque ela é ruim porque o meia
seja um alerta para você evitar mudança
com todo custo na sua vida
mas por que o medo nos lembra que nós
estamos diante do novo eo novo é como
estarmos enfrentando e vivenciando uma
área para além dos limites que a gente
conhece
por isso a morte nos coloca tanto
aumento dos limites estão aqui e toda
área conhecida é a área que está dentro
da nossa zona de conforto e essa foi uma
das grandes lições que o paraquedismo
trouxe aquele avião aquele vôo era está
dentro da minha zona de conforto e tudo
aquilo que a gente experimenta fora vai
causar medo vai causar desconforto mas
aí algo mágico acontece quando nós vamos
em direção ao desconforto
conscientemente
quando nós escolhemos o desconforto
acontece que ao invés de estar numa área
desse tamanho à medida que nós vamos
experimentando um novo fora dessa área
eu vou lá uma vez eu vou lá duas vezes
eu vou lá três vezes o que acontece é
que daqui a pouco de tanto ir lá no novo
ele se torna conhecido e graças a ser
conhecido ele passa a ser também uma
parte das suas zonas de conforto e aí a
sua zona de conforto aumenta e menos
situações ficam desconfortáveis em menos
uma gravidez na adolescência vai fazer
você sentir que vai morrer e - um salto
de paraquedas vai se colocar numa
posição de eu vou morrer e - a
transformação que você sente que precisa
criar para a sua vida vai paralisar por
que você enfrentou um novo eo novo a
gente não enfrenta uma jornada de mil
milhas
a gente enfrenta dando um passo de cada
vez
esses passos me levaram a hoje tem uma
filha que celebra seus 18 anos
esses passos me levaram ao topo do monte
roraima levaram a percorrer os 800
quilômetros de caminhos de santiago e me
trouxeram aqui esses passos são capazes
de me salvar
salvando a minha vida eu salvo o mundo
obrigada muito obrigada
[Aplausos]